clear is greater than clever i thought
titles were clever because i looked at
four hour work week and i was like oh
that's so clever right but that's not
what it is you don't want them to say
what is that you want them to say
how do i get that
think media podcast i am so fired up for
today's episode with rory vaden now if
you're just meeting rory he's the new
york times bestselling author of
multiple books that are definitely worth
checking out procrastinate on purpose
take the stairs but he's also started
multiple seven and eight figure
companies he's an expert in personal
branding and helping you clarify and
monetize your message and he's a
world-class human being family man
leader he works with some of the best
and the brightest influencers that you
would know and today he's going to be
breaking down insights on how we can
title our projects better titles are so
important he actually shared these tips
with me in nashville
at his headquarters and we learned about
the five title tests so we have a lot to
cover today on the podcast so buckle
your seat belts and rory welcome back to
the podcast how's it going today
man i'm doing great i'm fired up and uh
yeah i will say this right up front we
have never shared the content we're
gonna share here at this depth in a free
training ever um like this is usually
something we teach for the members and
uh those of you that are watching on the
youtube channel you can you can see the
backyard which is where you were sean
you were over here at the house and we
were having a casual conversation among
uh friends and this this topic came up
mostly from
the most expensive marketing mistake i
ever have made in my life and and i say
i everything is we my wife and i uh
built our former company together we
sold that in 2018 it was a roll-up of um
five different pnls that were all you
know seven-figure businesses um aj is my
co-founder of brand builders group she's
the ceo of the company um you know also
my wife mother of our our two boys and
so we do everything together but this
this content around titles
is particularly important because it's
it's heartbreaking like for me
personally
this is the most expensive mistake that
i've ever made in terms of a technical
mistake because i didn't understand
what makes a great title
which is what we were talking about in
the vaden villa backyard and then you
were like dude we're going to make this
into a podcast so never been shared
before
well i'm fired up and i don't want to
take too
long before we get into it but um i
think
some context around why this was even a
conversation and to see it a little bit
on the podcast heather taurus is
releasing her first book
in probably the first quarter of 2022 so
that's something to
get ready for and that's you know when
you're thinking about writing a book
you're thinking about man how do i come
up with a good book title and you're
like well there's actually title tests
and i was like well what are the tests
and you're like oh there's five of them
um but if you're listening to the
podcast today you know it might not be a
book that you want to write but maybe
you even want to make a title for a
compelling freemium or lead magnet that
you want everyone to download maybe
want to name an online course or a mini
course that you create and there could
be the difference between
a name that just really creates interest
and gets people pumped or just kind of
falls flat doesn't sound that
interesting maybe you're trying to name
your youtube channel or maybe you're
trying to name a show
on your youtube channel or a podcast you
know um this podcast is just called our
brand name the think media podcast but
recently i was uh listening to an
episode where they were brainstorming
names and and there was a vegan content
creator and they're like what if you
called your show the vegan wars or what
did you what have you called your show
the yummy vegan they're just they were
going through you know naming different
brands when it comes to social media or
shows within our brands is an incredibly
important aspect of what we do and so
let's get into the test rory what's
what's uh what's the first test
yeah so um the the the first test is
called the i want blank test and it is
the
the simplest
and we believe the single most profound
test um
and and
it's this simple and and when i tell you
you're going to be like no way but i'm
telling you we analyze titles we have
clients on the new york times bestseller
list we're watching titles constantly
and again this points back to the
biggest mistake that i've ever made in
my life which i'll fill you in on as we
kind of go but the first test is so
simple
is you just take your title
and you insert it at the end of this
phrase i want blank
if you can take your title or your
proposed title and drop it in at the end
of that sentence and if it's a oh hell
yeah then that's a great title but if it
is a what does that mean if it is a no
that doesn't make sense if it is or if
it's not something that you want it
doesn't work and
some of the greatest book titles and you
know brand builders group we are mostly
we do one-on-one coaching for brands and
so we help people with like you know
book launches is one of the things that
comes up in their their course of their
time with us so we're it's not just for
books specifically but if you just think
about books
the single greatest title that we will
probably see in the history of our
lifetime is four hour work week
i want a four hour work week um
everybody gets it um that applies to
everybody it is it is super clear on
exactly uh what it is
um but there's lots of examples to this
sean so you've got um there are hundreds
of thousands of bible devotionals like
daily devotionals that have been created
but the one that sold tens of millions
of copies purpose-driven life by rick
warren i want a purpose-driven life um i
want the secret i want to win friends
and influence people i want good to
great i want to think and grow rich
that's amazing i don't even have to do
anything i can just think and grow rich
it is it's epic uh this goes on and on
and on uh dave ramsey i want financial
peace robert cialdini i want influence t
harvecker i want secrets of the
millionaire mind um tony robbins
released a one of his more recent books
i want money like the title of the book
is called money and um
it is i want seven habits of highly
effective people i want the happiest
baby on the block like if you're a mom
you know with a baby you've heard of
this book the happiest baby on the block
i want blank well
with my second book
um
the book is is uh what we did was we
released that we have strategically
planned to release my ted talk
at the same time my book came out and we
thought oh man if we could have a viral
ted talk that went with the book right
at the same time that would be the
ultimate here's what happened they both
came out at the same time same messenger
same exact content my ted talk went
viral we have like 4 million views it's
it's i do get hired a lot for speaking
off of it but my book doesn't sell that
well i mean we've sold 10 like 30 000
units or something through retail but
much less than our first book take the
stairs
and and why well
procrastinate on purpose is the name of
the book i thought it was so clever i
was like oh no one's ever heard that
it's so intriguing it's it's you know
like you you're gonna go like what is
that like i've never i can't believe
that like what is that but when they
asked me for the title the ted talk i
didn't even think about it they just
said what's it about and i said oh how
to multiply time
well i want to multiply time
hell yeah it's the one thing everybody
wants and we literally figured out how
to multiply time like it's not an
exaggeration it's a world-changing view
on time management but i want to
procrastinate on purpose
and
doesn't pass the test it it nobody wants
to procrastinate we want the opposite of
procrastination we want action like we
want results we want progress it is so
simple just take whatever you're
thinking of your title drop it in i want
blank if it if it passes you're you're
90 of the way there
and this is just test one of five and so
if you can pass all five tests because
probably i think about you know and we
could talk about this live here what do
you think about youtube secrets i mean
people i want youtube secrets i do i
probably want the secrets of youtube is
that pretty good yeah here's why so
that's actually a good fit sean to the
second test which is the clarity test
okay so i want youtube secrets if you
take these five title tests you could
basically score each of them
individually which is what we will do
for our clients like we will give them a
grade on each of these and then we'll
come up with an average grade and we'll
go this is this is how we think this
title will perform and it's it's
shockingly accurate but the second test
is called the clarity test
um
it's this simple the more a title needs
to be explained the less effective it is
and
procrastinate on purpose okay to use
myself as a horrible case study again
right
the book is not about procrastinating
the book is about how to multiply time
i'll tell you the premise of the whole
book and ted talk is this you multiply
time by spending time on things today
that create more time tomorrow that's
how you multiply time you spend time on
things today that create more time
tomorrow well procrastinate on purpose
is one of the five techniques because if
you can procrastinate on the trivial
stuff the stupid stuff then that creates
margin for yourself that you can then
use to reallocate into the things that
multiply your time the things you spend
time on today that give you more time
tomorrow
okay
the fact that it just took me 37 seconds
to explain what procrastinate on purpose
means doesn't mean the concept's bad
it's a great it's a righteous concept it
means it sucks as a title
on the other hand when i say multiply
your time
what do you think that book is about
there is no confusion
it's completely clear and if you're
taking notes here's what i want you to
write down this is this is the big
lesson on this one
clear is greater than clever
clear is greater than clever i thought
titles were clever because i looked at
four hour work week and i was like oh
that's so clever right but that's not
what it is
it's not about it clever it's about
being clear
you don't want people to say what is
that see i actually accomplished the
objective i set out with procrastinate
on purpose people read it and they go
that's interesting what is that i've
never heard of that
but that's not what you want them to do
so i accomplished the objective i just
accomplished the wrong objective the
objective is not to get them to say
wow what is that i've never heard of
that or that's different or that's
unique or interesting you don't want
them to say what is that you want them
to say
how do i get that
so you don't want a title to be
intriguing
you want a title to be enticing
and that was how we failed the second
test which was the clarity test so we're
automatically off to a bad start with
the title um procrastinating on purpose
and that's you know this is why the book
isn't selling as well
and would you say
because i love that you know on your
personal brand your business
anything online if you confuse you lose
clarity is power that's a donald miller
if you confuse you lose that's a donald
miller yep and if you want
clever is good would you would you say
clever is good if it's not at the
sacrifice of clarity because four hour
work work week is clever but it's still
completely clear as far as what it's
about so if you could do both should you
try to do both
i think you
you it's possible but what i would say
is don't pursue clever like clever is
not you by pursuing clever all you're
gonna do is risk clarity and you're not
gonna gain that much
instead of pursuing intriguing pursue
enticing four-hour work week works not
because it's clever it works because
it's enticing we all
want a four-hour work week here's
another way of thinking about this and
this was you know again this is
something we tell our our coaching
clients all the time because i was so
bad at this like this you can probably
tell it's it's it's still heartbreaking
for me to teach and talk on this but if
you were to think about this as a trip
right
the um
the title should be the destination
the content is the vehicle
okay so
the
what a lot of people do is is they try
to market what we say they market the
message they try to market the vehicle
so that's another common mistake is
they'll take their message and they'll
make their message the title um and that
is a mistake you want to market the
destination market where people end up
don't market the journey don't market
the vehicle
market the destination um
people want to end up with multiplying
time procrastinate on purpose is one of
five vehicles that we teach in the book
for how to create margin to multiply
time but we're we were marketing a one
of the vehicles rather than the
destination which was how to multiply
time and you actually see this a lot a
lot of times people
will try to have a clever title and then
they'll have a clear subtitle and they
missed it it's like they should if
anything they should flip it the
subtitle should be you know first
because it's like this is what you get
as a result of downloading this lead
magnet watching this free course reading
this blog article like listening to this
podcast episode um
you know like so yeah that's the clarity
test we might have discussed this before
too and and i like filtering because i
immediately started to think about my
personal
properties my brands the things i've
titled and one is our signature course
it's called video ranking academy we
have something like 8 000 students in it
people love it
i was thinking
that it is the vehicle i'm not fully
explaining the vehicle there's seven r's
in it
and the destination having ranked videos
is good but as i have been through the
years now in the iterations of the
course and then i'm hearing your title
test
i want to rank my videos on youtube well
probably true um is it clear okay well
if you understand ranking and that
sometimes needs to be explained but in
hindsight i've thought i want to be a
full-time youtube creator or i want to
have the path to or or a youtube
millionaire or whatever any thoughts
just on these first two tests my
signature product is called video
ranking academy what would you score
that on the uh clarity so you're just
going for free consulting here now i
understand that's why i'm here okay so
if you were to think about a continuum
on this side right at the beginning
would be um confusing
then you would have intriguing
right then you would have enticing
then you would have irresistible
but then on the far end depending on
your brand i would say you have
unbelievable
okay
so you gotta play your game on this
continuum so video ranking academy
i would score that as pretty high i
would i would score that as enticing not
irresistible irresistible would be viral
video academy or video traffic academy
um or you know video
you know
video viewership academy maybe like
those those kind of things academy is
clear academy signals or suggests
a course or a program so that's good
videos is clear you know
youtube would be even more narrow which
could be good or bad depending on what
you're going for but video ranking
academy is very solid i would give that
a b plus or an a minus you could press
the limits by going viral video academy
i want viral videos like that would be
more on this spectrum now
pushing it a little further you would
say
youtube millionaire
i'm pretty sure a book called become a
youtube millionaire would crush sean
like it probably would crush at some
point you got to figure out
how does that reconcile with your brand
characteristics there's a exercise we
take clients through called our brand
characteristics list um
and if you push it too far you kind of
start to approach the there's a slime in
this factor there's a dis an unbelief
factor there's a there's a gimmicky
factor that starts to show up so it's a
balance but video ranking academy is is
solid i think you could press the limits
more
and again if you think about that that
metaphor of the journey that you're
taking people on um
you know if you're going from san
francisco to new york and new york is
viral video academy
i think video ranking academy is like
virginia like you're you're you're
pretty far out there whereas if you
called it the seven r's to great videos
now you're back in arizona
um so i it's this continuum and we're
constantly trying to
evaluate and kind of you know balance um
you know these are just two of the tests
though there's other there's other tests
that also factor and i'm excited to get
into test three i like that you brought
up you know also having your own brand
awareness like knowing what your own
brand dna is as you described because i
probably wouldn't want to create the
course write the book called youtube
millionaire to your point like i would i
personally but for you because it'd be
off brand for me for sure uh but man
these tests are so powerful and and by
the way today's episode is brought to
you by
freebrandcall.com forward slash think
that is actually how you can get a free
strategy call uh with rory's team at
brand builders
we've been working with them in fact uh
we i recently just went through some
coaching for
my personal brand and thinking about
navigating the next couple years of
where do i want to go where's think
media going i think if you haven't
listened to the other episode in our
library where rory talked all about
personal branding you'll discover that
he has a particular set of skills that
makes him incredibly powerful he and his
team for how do you build and monetize
your personal brand and how do you
really stand out in a crowded
marketplace so anyways um the cool thing
about a strategy call is of course
there's ways to work with him and his
team but you will learn so much just on
the free call in terms of assessing
where you're at on the journey
et cetera so again you can check that on
the show notes
freebrandcall.com forward slash think if
you want to get access to that and can't
recommend them enough that's who we work
with in terms of
shaping and developing our personal
brand we're only on just two tests so
far and man if you already passed these
tests well you probably be ahead of most
people titling their books products and
programs but what's number three
yeah so number three also extremely
simple it's called the positive energy
test
so
words colors
and images
all have energy
this is deeply rooted in
the neuroscience of the human brain and
let me tell you one of the ways we
figured this out was from my son jasper
when he was three years old so
if you come in i'm a huge book nerd i'm
just a reader i've always been a
personal development just geek that's
how i got into the industry right as
basically spent 20 years like reading
and studying all these books but in my
office i've got hundreds of business
books and personal development books and
all this stuff well
when our three-year-old son jasper walks
into my office
out of hundreds of books
he will always grab the same book
the book is called made to stick
it's written by chip and dan heath
it's actually a really great book
but jasper cannot read
clearly he's not interested in the
subject matter clearly he's not a fan of
the authors clearly
it's not the title that grabbed his
attention what is it well if you've ever
seen that book made to stick by chip and
dan heath the entire book is bright
flamboyant orange the whole book is
bright orange jasper is drawn to the
color
um
and so
we noticed this trend started to happen
in fact going back to four hour work
week some of you will remember when the
book first came out and tim ferriss is
just such a freaking genius in so many
ways and uh marketing for sure
originally that book came out it was
white and it had like kind of a deep
gold bottom it was like split um
but when they re-released the revised
edition
the whole book is bright orange
right so it has that positive energy
and then what's the image on the cover
the image on the cover a four-hour work
week is a dude and a hammock
laying around between two palm trees
um
so simple and clear and powerful and
brilliant um and so
words colors um images
uh gretchen rubin is somebody who's a
friend of ours not not a brand builders
group client but she's done you know
we've had her on our podcast she's done
some free trainings for our community
etc
gretchen rubin's biggest selling book is
the happiness project what is the word
the giant word across the cover
happiness i want happiness
giant um
there is uh
you know john gordon is a good friend of
ours he's written dozens of books the
book that sells the most it's been like
a over a decade since it's come out it
still says two sells two thousand units
every single work every single week the
book is called the energy bus
bright yellow cover biggest word right
across the center of of the cover energy
in big in big letters
um by the way
the word procrastinate okay with the
word multiply
positive or negative energy sean
fill it in for us here positive energy
positive positive multiply exponential
growth expansive like uh it's hugely
positive how about the word
procrastinate
negative
most negative word in the english
language other than death right and i
fought to have this word not only across
the cover i fought for it to be
emboldened i wanted raised lettering i
was so convinced this was such a good
title what idiot
would ever
use this word procrastinate um
procrastinate uh right across the cover
so it's it's it's terrible but there's
so many examples here's another great
one okay i've never read this book but
it has sold i think nine ten million
copies um there are so many books sean
on home organizing so many and from what
i understand about this particular book
it's not a bad book but it's also not
revolutionary in a way of home
organizing that is saying things that
nobody has ever said or thought of but
the book is called the life-changing
magic of tidying up
life-changing magic of tidying up
marie condo's second book was called
spark joy
also sold four four or five million
copies um
so
it's it's so simple right even even
words uh even titles uh which we'll talk
about why this one works in a second the
fifth title test um the subtle art of
not giving an f okay so
f you know the f word is negative energy
but if that book okay
what's the color what's the color of the
cover
bright orange once again like it's it's
bright it's attention grabbing uh it
pulls you in and also people don't what
do i want i want to not give an f i want
to be free from stress that's another
way of saying it but you know not given
f actually has a bit of a positive
energy whereas it's like you know live
stress free the word stress is risky
even though i do want to live stress
free putting the word stress in big
letters across the cover just like the
word procrastinate
it's a risky word it's not about the
logical coherence of the sentence
structure or the title it's each
independent individual word a word like
ranking
is positive energy like it's it's a
positive energy and it's not over that
it's not over the top words like viral
are positive energy words like
millionaire positive energy um so it's
the positive energy test and it's again
super super duper simple chicken soup
for the soul is positive energy daring
greatly positive energy
one of our other good friends hal elrod
miracle morning miracle big giant word
across the cover positive energy um
that's the third test
so number one i want blank i want to
think and grow rich clarity test number
two
um how do i get that how do i ultimately
understand how do i think and grow rich
i want to be enticed number three
positive energy test
and so what's number four
all right so number four is a little bit
more nuanced this one is called the
native tongue test
the native tongue test
anytime you can use a title
that specifically
triggers like a a niche audience
it often is very effective because
um part of how you cut through the noise
is by speaking with specificity that's a
strategy for cutting through noise and
if you listen to the other training that
that shawn and i did you'll hear us talk
about sheehan's wall and this concept of
uh how there's
the biggest problem is noise and you get
absorbed into the noise and how do you
create how do you put out a signal that
is pristine and distinct and clear of
all that noise
or if you do the free call with us but
the native tongue is a way to send a
very clear signal that cuts through the
noise it speaks precisely to your avatar
and there's some great examples of this
um what to expect when you're expecting
okay if you are up if you're a mother
and you're having your first child again
it does pass the i want test i want to
know what to expect when you're
expecting
um but it's really native tongue it it
grabs a mom happiest baby on the block
it grabs a a mom
there's a huge book the last few years
that's been out it's called never split
the difference um
it's by chris voss who is a former fbi
hostage negotiator and it's about how to
negotiate well if you're someone who
negotiates for a living split the
difference
is a is a phrase it's a vernacular that
speaks to you you know exactly what that
means so anyone who's interested in
negotiation
it it signals
like again in a very precise pristine
a clear
way
this book is for you um
blitz scaling is another great example
of a book that's been out like if you
are in the silicon valley and you're in
that vc world of like funding you know
finding unicorns and funding them and
growing them quickly and selling them
off for millions of dollars blitz
scaling
is a term that entrepreneurs uh under
understand uh the lean startup you know
is another book that's
really lends itself well to
uh this this native tongue so
one of the exercises by the way all
like every lesson that we teach
we couple all these lessons with
exercises that we put people through um
to help them like apply this so one of
the exercises here is super simple we
just say make a list of all of the
jargon
that your audience uses terms that no
one else uses that are specific to them
right youtube secrets is native tongue
test it
half of being found
is being
unfound on purpose like being overlooked
on purpose right so you know if i'm if
i'm looking for social media tactics in
general
youtube secrets might speak to me but it
it might not but if i'm not interested
in youtube i'm automatically
self-selecting out of your audience but
but when you make it so clear that
someone can select out of your audience
by virtue of doing that you're also
making it very clear who should
self-select into that audience like what
to expect when you're expecting um
so
this one is i would say
less ubiquitous it's it's a you know i i
probably wouldn't for me personally
you know i'm so convicted we're so
convicted aj and i like our podcast
is is you know a very boring title the
reason we went with boring is because
it's clear so right because it's like i
will never
fail that test again the i want test and
the clarity test so native tongue's a
little bit riskier um but it's
boy it could be super effective great
thing to use as a test on the lead
magnet or the name of a video or a blog
article something that you're not
anchored to the rest of your career
man i love that and it was interesting
because never split the difference um
uh is a book i've heard about was
recommended is something i'd probably be
a an outsider audience that would like
and i ended up buying the book i haven't
read it yet because because of the
reviews because it was recommended but
as you said that's a term
insiders would understand and by putting
never
there's also like a shock to that it
kind of reminds me of
like jesus communicating who uh you know
we both agree is among among other
things powerful in our life one of the
best communicators the best communicator
leader
and he would often say like you've heard
it said
and he would quote something people
understood but then he would take a
contrarian approach but i tell you
it's not an eye for an eye tooth virtue
i'd say turn the other cheek and he
would then share this illuminating
so is that kind of
what never split the difference is doing
it's sort of saying okay
if there's maybe jargon in your industry
or mindsets in your industry
like strengthsfinders
incredibly powerful i've heard it taught
even by some to say
uh
i mean i would say who was i remember
brenda burchard was saying
strengths finders isn't even relevant
anymore he's actually like whether true
or not he was taking a polarizing
contrarian approach by saying new data
would tell us and and actually saying so
what's in the audience's mind
and then of course not being a gimmick
but
with conviction by potentially being
polarizing to that is there a strategy
that could be used there could that be a
way to use date of tongue because they
understand the jargon but you're taking
a contrarian approach
uh yeah potentially but um look i want
to strength finder i want to find my
strengths we just interviewed tom rath
on our podcast a few weeks ago
that book is sold 10 million copies it's
the number one all-time best-selling
book on amazon there's no book on amazon
that has sold more than that book like
uh so
you can take the here's what being
contrarian does
um it grabs attention
uh and
uh this actually points to the fifth
test sean the fifth test is what we call
the memorability test the memorability
test being remembered is half the battle
and gaining someone's attention is the
only way to even have a chance to be
remembered so brendan burchard who is
also a brilliant marketer
if he comes out and says something like
that's irrelevant it's going to capture
attention it's going to capture interest
in eyeballs but then you're going to
have to quickly segue to something
that's super valuable or you know
whatever
but
i think you know it's about grabbing
attention it's what clickbait is
clickbait is grabbing attention it works
right like uh you know come see inside
angela jolie's you know private bathroom
right people are gonna click on that
like um the you know 10 most disgusting
surgeries that have ever happened
people are gonna are gonna click on that
because it it's it is shocking um and
again half the battle here is just
breaking through the noise it's just
being seen and so there's these
different ways to do that but you you
got to do it
click bait to me is a very low form way
of doing it but in some ways the i want
blank test is kind of it is kind of that
way you know so it's it's a gradient
scale here um but the memorability test
uh this is where shock factor shows up
this is also where metaphors show up so
by the way right so um
procrastinate on purpose we've talked
about why this book the titles suck but
take the stairs was the first book
i want to take the stairs nope doesn't
pass that is it clear not really take
the stairs
uh you know it sounds a little bit like
is there a fire or you know is this an
exercise book i'm if you've never heard
it but
the the um
it's not it's kind of positive energy
it's a little bit active energy it's
certainly not native tongue test unless
there's a group of you know avid stair
climbers out there in the world but
here's where here's where take the
stairs wins
if you've ever read the take this stairs
book or if you've ever heard my
signature take the stairs talk
about how most people in life take the
escalator but the truth about success is
it's not about taking the escalator
success is about taking the stairs doing
the things you know you should be doing
that you don't feel like doing
if you've ever read the book or heard me
give that talk you will never
ever
ever
look at an escalator and not think of me
the anchor is so strong the metaphor is
so strong and clear that people remember
it and they actually do it people are in
the airport with a group of friends
everyone gets on the escalator one
person takes the stairs why are you
doing this ah it's this book i read
about blah blah blah blah and it
so take the stairs it has a long tail
it sells well long-term because it
propagates naturally the problem with
take the stairs is it's not enticing so
it doesn't attract strangers so it
propagates very nicely through the
existing community and fans but it
doesn't appeal to people if they've
never heard of me like if they don't
know me they've never heard me explain
it they're not gonna just buy it off the
shelf
they will though go oh you know what i
think my friend was telling me about
this book
and and it and it's very memorable um
you know there's some other reasons why
but that's that's why take the stairs
cells well is it scores off the chart on
the memorability test for the people who
actually read it um this is why cuss
words work cuss words are memorable um
and and they are pattern interrupts
you know the subtle but here's what's
interesting about cuss words because you
see a lot of these right now you are a
bad a the subtle art of not giving an f
you know
you know unf yourself and and a lot of
these titles have done really well
the more that people start to use cuss
words and titles the less effective that
strategy will become uh is is what we
think now
they're always still shocking so what a
customer does is it gets you attention
but it also creates risk because it's
going to turn some people off right it's
it's it you know in a corporate market
like in the keynote speaking market
where you know we built a lot of our
career originally was
you know i get paid a lot of money to
come and do a keynote hard for someone
to hire
you know the guy to that uses f-bombs
all over this and and that and
everywhere in a corporate environment
now for associations it's a different
story where it's a bunch of individuals
coming so you know there's there's
trade-offs here but um girl wash your
face great example fails all the other
tests it's not something you want it's
not clear it's not really positive
energy it's not native tongue other than
girl is pretty native tongue um
but wash your face as a metaphor rachel
hollis is saying dust yourself off right
like just wash your face and keep going
it's a metaphor brian tracy has written
dozens of book his best-selling book of
all time eat that frog why because if
you eat a frog first thing in the
morning i.e do your most difficult task
first thing in the morning the rest of
your day will be easier
if you don't if you just see eat that
frog and you have no context you're not
going to buy that book but anyone who's
read it eat that frog becomes a part of
their culture their language they think
about it they use it every day
um
and you know it it propagates it
propagates nicely so
these are the tests and brian tracy's
book i would argue has become
to appoint some cultural vernacular even
for people who have not read it that
really has reverberated i've never read
the book i was familiar that he wrote it
understood the concept maybe i heard him
describe it in a leadership talk or an
audio sound bite i kind of got the big
idea and it was brought up on one of our
staff meetings recently um
for again whether people have read it or
not they're like oh yeah that's that's
that mindset of get up early um well i
love it listen we're gonna do a
lightning round because uh uh you know
if you're getting value and you're
watching or listening to this on youtube
of course we'd love if you drop a like
if you want to try to
coerce rory to come back on the podcast
in the future these are some of the most
valuable episodes this is really like a
master class that can be helpful to us
in just a second i kind of want to take
rory's wealth of knowledge and get his
point of view and perspective on some of
the top books out there some of my
favorite authors so we can learn from
that uh in a lightning round and we'll
maybe grade a few books and talk about
why they worked or not but i do want to
encourage you um one of the most
powerful things you can do if you want
to really strengthen your personal brand
is connect with uh rory and his team and
again this
episode today is brought to you by free
brand call.com forward slash think so
definitely take advantage of that
resource free call and uh they're gonna
give you a lot of strategy that you can
put into practice and maybe um going
deeper with them and working with them
will work if if it doesn't work hey take
advantage of some of the insights you
can get with them speaking directly into
your situation and the website for that
again is free
brand call
dot com forward slash think in our final
minutes here i think this could be one
of the most fun times i like rory i am
an avid reader i'm obsessed with books i
um i'm always i buy books all the time
amazon boxes are showing up to my house
all the time and i have a couple uh
favorite authors i am curious um
rory seth godin um
purple cow
title test
successful book um i'm not sure you know
how successful i know you have industry
insights memorability memorability it
passes the memorability test that also
has become vernacular in the marketing
world but
here's another thing sean you cannot
watch what famous authors do or famous
personal brands do and model off them
they've already broken through the wall
you have to look at people who are just
breaking through the wall or go back 20
years ago to how they broke through the
wall the other thing that you should
know on this is platform trumps all of
this if you have a huge audience if
you're oprah you can call your book
whatever the freak you want people are
gonna buy it because you're oprah you're
michelle obama it doesn't matter if
you're the rock call your book whatever
you want you're gonna sell a ton but if
you're rory vaden and not everybody
knows you and you're just one voice
amongst the sea of noise that's where
this stuff and so that's where you got
to be careful looking at celebrities and
seth has spent years and years and
decades building followership he built a
platform he has consistency set and now
he has so much reputation it doesn't
matter but purple cow wins because of
the memorability test not the others
we're getting into the gold right here
because that right there is a major
unlock you don't want to be we encourage
people to do that on youtube they go
well well casey neistat vlogs like this
why can't i just vlog about my daily
life
you're like well okay let's like play it
back
to where he is today and and how you
know what did he do when he started
that's a powerful question and so let's
talk about gary vaynerchuk he launches
crush it number one which i think pass
all kinds of tests why now is the time
to cash in on your passion
in fact that was the very book in 2009
that originally
that launched
even launched it launched him that's how
i discovered him so later on he can
launch askgaryvee which is an insular
name it's just
but it doesn't matter because platform
trumps everything platform trump's
everything yeah yeah you can't you go
yeah garyvee doesn't matter he's in that
but think about crush it i want to crush
it it's clear um it's positive energy
right now the book the book cover was
black if i remember but the words crush
it if i remember are bright green um but
you know i think if he would re-release
that as bright green and then the and
then the the things were black that
would be better but but very clear and
and cash in on your passion i mean that
that might have even been a better title
again to take the subtitle cash in on
your passion great subtitle four-hour
work week by the way
you know escape the nine to five and
join the new rich
these guys are geniuses
man that's incredible any and
gary did do a version 2.0 crushing it
and it was yellow so it went the total
it was sort of that uh
dan heath book you were recommending
right or mentioning uh made to stick
it's sort of that same idea a bright
color took it a whole different
direction than that original color
on garyvee jab jab jab right hook
it it's not a good title it's a great
concept give give give ask but there's
two things there one it needs to be
explained and two
that is the message not that's the
vehicle not the destination he's putting
the strategy on the cover here's what
you should do
right like you know the
something around like you know the
secret to creating conversions would
work a lot better but again
that garyvee is a straightforward guy
he's a he's a to your face guy and and
by that point you know platform didn't
matter but so i love gary vee like you
know in a lot of ways i love this stuff
and follow but
i would have told him i would have said
don't don't call the book that and i
think it would have done better
rich dad poor dad oh my gosh i mean
anything with the word rich
pretty much an automatic victory like
even take a self-published book and go
through amazon and look at the ones with
the word rich like they're they're going
they're going to do great now um
uh so you have that i would also say
that's a great book you know robert
kiyosaki is actually the one who said
remember it's not called new york times
best writing author it's new york times
best-selling author we remind our
clients of that a lot it is um it is a
marketing game but long term
the writing does matter it doesn't have
to be you know nobel prize winning or
you know pulitzer prize winning but you
know the four cash flow quadrants and
all the stuff that robert kiyosaki does
in that book super clear but but again
any book about money any book about look
and just go look at what the mainstream
people do and we you know we have some
clients that are very very mainstream
people
anything on money or sex like or health
is gonna pretty much perform well or
celebrities those are gonna perform well
those are all things people want um and
so you know those are topics that are
universally applicable
grit
so yeah this one is another one that um
has become part of pop culture and
vernacular uh angela duckworth's done
great um you're now seeing that word
being yeah just a part of the you know
the nomenclature which shows the
pervasiveness of the idea um
so i want grit
it's clear
um pretty positive i think you know grit
there's something about grit that is
like
easier to digest than just hard work
um
super clear kind of positive energy
honestly i think that angela is a great
communicator she's super intelligent has
a lot of connections um you know had a
big platform big platform right so you
know
uh ted talk big stages those those
things make a difference but but you
know i i think grit is probably a b-plus
ego is the enemy
terrible title um terrible title now
ryan holiday freaking brilliant
brilliant writer brilliant marketer
brilliant thinker i think ryan is is is
brilliant now um
i mean
so
here's what ego of the ego is the enemy
does a good job of it it's very clear
about what the book is about but ego is
a tough word to put on the cover i don't
want an ego i don't want an enemy
positive energy test it fails you know i
think i think there could have been a
stronger title there
but
ryan holiday
huge platform super intelligent lots of
connections not his first book an
incredible writer so it still wins but i
would say that one wins in spite of the
title not because of the title similar
to like a you know jab jab jab right
hook hmm and i wonder
i i would imagine ryan's strategy
was not by accident that he went trilogy
and went
obstacle is the way ego is the enemy
still this is the key i believe well i'm
probably very intentional but who knows
if that was the idea from the beginning
in doing so you maybe only need
you start to build a long tail
reputation if one book does well
it might not matter i i mean we're
talking about self-help non-fiction but
if you go hunger games and that book
starts well eventually you're going to
want to listen to catching fire or read
you know and maybe finish it out so
because they all had the same cadence
they he kept it the title of each of
them sort of the same and to that to
that you know this came up earlier sean
i don't think you know i think ryan
probably does everything pretty
deliberately i i don't actually i
haven't met him personally yet but i
have a lot of respect for him um
and i think there's a deliberate choice
there of going he wants to be aligned
with kind of the stoicism and that's
something that he's fascinated by in
studies and so he
he can afford to back off the title test
because it's a conscious choice to go i
want my brand to be associated with
something he's not desperate for the
attention or desperate for the audience
like somebody newer in their journey
brilliant i mean when you synthesize all
these ideas rory we have the title test
but we also need to learn so many other
things too because if we know our brand
dna if we also know the big
picture we're playing towards it's kind
of like advice i've received where these
are real rules they're powerful rules
you may intentionally break them but we
have that much more power by knowing
what they are and what we may be
sacrificing in order to
pick the title we want or whatever it is
so
five titles
everything we do at brand builders group
is playing the odds right we're just
playing the odds right you know people
like dave ramsey or ryan holiday they
rarely like that neither of those people
are clients they don't hire us they
don't they don't need us now we do work
with a lot of pretty
big well-known people um but a lot of
times you reach a point where it's like
this stuff matters less because it's not
an exact science um in fact one of the
things that we tell our our clients you
know we're playing the odds here this
our best guest all of these are
hypotheses we're teaching you things
that we've learned from these painful
mistakes that we've made that we've seen
our clients make one of our clients
hired us to we we had two clients
um two different clients hire us to help
them with their ted talk they both
requested advice on what their title
should be
one of them listened to us the other one
deviated on purpose the one who deviated
didn't get much going the one who
listened to us she has almost three
million ted talk views in less than two
years she just got a six-figure book
deal it's you're playing the odds we
can't guarantee things you know and
there are things that that buck the
system just like you go play blackjack
uh i don't i don't play blackjack but if
you go gamble you don't have to follow
the rules occasionally you get lucky
right like you can bet it all on black
and win
but
you probably long term you wanna you
wanna do your best to play the odds um
but you know you don't let the science
get in the way of the art
it's still an art it's still an instinct
personal branding is still about what do
you feel connected to what do you want
to be known for
you know and and you know someone like
ryan holliday goes i want this is how i
want to be position this i want to
position myself super elegant and a lot
of power to that
absolutely brilliant um
if you haven't watched the other episode
with rory in our library check it out he
goes deep in a lot of their frameworks
and strategy for strengthening your
personal brand definitely take advantage
of connecting with uh brand builders at
freebrandcall.com forward slash think
and then rory you're on social media as
well i love following you on instagram
where you're continually adding nuggets
of value and a lot of different things
so if people want to follow up with you
and connect with you where is the best
place they can uh follow you and where
are you most active
yeah that's where i'm most active is is
instagram
it's the one social media platform i've
like really gotten into and um so yeah
come over dm me a question say hi um but
but uh you know freebrandcall.com think
would be really the place to go if you
want to connect up
rory vaden thank you so much
my pleasure brother all the best are you
ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at
dot
thinkmasterclass.com
[Music]
[Music]